what is that world that simulates that
travels back in time into the Martian
landscape what does the science reveal
so the science reveals that
life is resilient when I started that
project I told my husband I say this is
going to be very fast we are going in
such nasty environment that we are not
going to find anything and in a world
back home uh fairly soon
so 20 years later we are still studying
those environments that was a gut
feeling like nothing not much can
possibly survive well the the UV
environment is so nasty but there you
find the same microorganism that made
the very first fossils on Earth 3.5
billion years ago
and they keep surviving they developed
an adaptation
Swiss armina if you prefer
and so you learn about that you learn
about what they are how they adapt
through times and through environmental
changes which is really important what
are their signatures we learn to
recognize them we learn what kind of
instrument we need what kind of of
signature whether it's chemical or
morphological or whatnot so basically we
learn how to explore but I would say
that to me and this is a realization
interestingly enough that came three
years into the project
uh I really woke up literally one
morning saying you know we have been
coming here for three years now try and
understand how to search for Life on
Mars but what this place is showing us
is what's happening right here right now
on our own planet
and uh by exploring those extreme
environments we are also reaching to
places not too many people go and so
we're learning more about our own
biospheres and uh the diversity of our
own life here on Earth so these are the
two main things you know that I would
say what kind of life
survives up there
well those volcanoes it's about bacteria
you know mostly is there something
specific about that bacteria that's able
to be so rugged yes
um they have adapted to very high UV
radiation and it's not only because they
are at high altitude it's because early
Earth
didn't have an ozone layer so when those
the ancestors of those bacteria
originated they have to survive a world
where you had lots of short UV coming
down at the surface and also lots of
hydrothermal environment you know
volcanoes and hot water lots of salt and
you see all these toolbox
Steel
embedded in those microorganisms today 4
billion years later it's just amazing
and depending on the environment they
are going to switch some of these
defenses adaptation on or off
the UV
situation there is so nasty that
here you have bacterias like that so I
know bacteria you find them everywhere
it's really something you find all over
the place but if you find them here in
California they will turn their
protection against UV during the day in
summer and they will switch it off at
the end of the day
there in the Andes it's so nasty is that
that thing stays on all the time but if
you take samples and bring them back
here and start to
culture them like we did on top of a
building leaving them you know you will
see the second generation of this
organism they are starting to switch on
and off again
so they're extremely adaptable extremely
rugged and that's why they are still
here
and probably that's why we are here
because life finds ways so is there some
degree to which the harshness of the
conditions
enables
the flourishing of life versus shuts it
down
well it will shut down
those that cannot survive obviously you
know this is a statement that's Captain
Obvious right there but it's also
the survival of the fittest and this is
what evolution is right
so they are here because they were the
most adaptable
and so
evolution is going to show the path of
the fittest the one that cannot resist
they might have a good time for a little
while but then you know we've seen this
at much different scale and with complex
life not so long ago a hundred thousand
years ago
meanderthal
was side by side by Homo sapiens but
nandatho was completely adapted to a
cold Earth to a glacial Earth of the end
of the pleistocene
and when condition change
it couldn't last you think I mean
there's still some Mysteries around that
right like exactly exactly what were the
harshness of the conditions
um I still really suspicious what did
Homo sapiens do no no no I really want
to know no no I I'm Shady stuff that
happened shitty stuff happened they met
the bread together they fought against
each other
what humans do you had to expect that
but the thing is that Neanderthal was
completely adapted for a very long time
to leave at the edge of those glaciers
there were probably in a weekend
situation when Homo sapiens came uh and
and started to spread so
um basically this is what life does it
add apps and if you cannot add apps
anymore it disappeared and something
else takes over